it was a hometown kid I was a player the
Year candidate the bigger the moment the
better he was
[Applause]
I think I had five 40-point games that
season I was really rolling offensively
my expectation was afforded be honest
now let's head courtside along with
former Gonzaga standout Adam Morrison
nobody prepares you for fame I get
remembered for showing emotion but
during that season I felt that I was one
of the better players in college
basketball and I think I proved that
[Music]
[Applause]
it'd be very very friend and I wanted to
be like him in every aspect so it kind
of came in stock ously loved Larry Bird
mucked up Larry Bird I mean nobody
pocket was way up hide the mustache
everybody remembers his so that was part
of it looking back on it now there's
times where I'm like but also created a
brand for myself once you watch him for
awhile you realize it's it's different
and it's and it's unorthodox but it's
incredibly effective really really
really scored
[Applause]
it was fun because I had the ultimate
very light I could shoot
[Applause]
well I was obviously a very emotional
player crated they mentioned so much
media attention as well he had a
tendency to talk and that kind of got it
going that was just
[Music]
that year with Adam it was amazing not
only were we highly ranked but he was
such a an entity that everybody wanted
to see I mean he had to check in under
aliases and you know in hotels Dirk
Diggler I know I used Dirk Diggler for a
while which hopefully my kids don't
watch this then we walk into these
arenas and they were raring to go hours
before tip and and he would just thrive
in that environment
[Applause]
it was such a whirlwind around me you
know I look at a double-edged sword it
was great but also there was times was
like I just disappear and just be a
normal college kid I felt a little bit
bad and took away from kind of my other
teammates success but also it helped
elevate the program and gave us an
opportunity to take this step from you
know mid-major and now to a true
powerhouse there was so much pressure
because of who I was and how the season
progressed we thought we were a Final
Four team Adam Morrison and National
Player of the Year candidate trying to
put Gonzaga on his back on a tournament
run here a three seed a year but we
liked our draw eight a three late in
that game down the stretch to really
extend ourselves
a tough game against Indiana and
squeaked by in the second round
and then everybody knows the UCLA game
you see
good Sabbath
[Applause]
air comes the all America we admitted
sweet 16 my two years before that we
lost in the second round so there's a
lot of pressure on Boris it quick
release three we're looking ahead but
when you're up 17 at one point it's hard
not to a little bit
fly low block gets his own rebound
[Applause]
literally everything that had to go
right for them down the stretch did some
guys it's some pretty amazing shots for
them just one of those games
barbar runner got it it just kind of
happened in the fog more's it step back
jumper D off to here
[Applause]
that's one of my biggest regrets I
should have bounced him down and
probably got closer and try to get foul
and once I missed that everything kind
of domino effect and then got a little
bit crazy
[Applause]
[Applause]
are you
it is this [ __ ] go
look up forward down it was tough it was
tough to handle
to be honest I'm sure he heard times and
he probably still thinks about it to
this day good but he's done with the
cast
[Applause]
I was gonna go to the NBA and it was my
last game local kid and a Gonzaga kid
from my whole life it is very emotional
to to lose that way it wasn't like we
you know just got our butts kicked I
just showed emotion like that was we
were ahead 17 it's kind of how he's
wired which is this is what you respect
if it happened now I'd be poignant and
look at this man showing emotion how
great is this and all that stuff so I
you know it's funny how culture changes
and everything shifts but I was the
first guy to do it and it's so I got a
Hamburg for which is okay it happens but
if we win that game I'm never remembered
from that the previous guy who did the
the color took another job in town and
so they just called me one day so do you
want to give a shot I've never had any
experience there's times when I wish I
was wearing a uniform again because it'd
be fun to play in this often it helps me
stay around the game and watch
basketball for a living it's good good
life
I've had really good life experiences
because of basketball and especially
that see people have asked me just
whenever you're UCLA it is it free
Catholic it's alright it's one loss it
happens I'm not I'm not ashamed of
showing emotion to be honest
hey it's Master here with Br please
subscribe to check out some more great
video content